This first premultiplied texel would turn into this value. The 2.5 is clearly
out of range of a value that can be stored in a texel, in the range of 0 to 1.
So, this texel cannot be properly represented when unmultiplied. The second
texel would convert to values between 0 and 1. This is a valid unmultiplied
RGBA. To convert this third texel to unmultiplied form, the alpha value would
have to be used to divide the RGB values. Dividing a non 0 number by 0 is
illegal. So, this premultiplied RGBA value cannot be converted and stored in
unmultiplied form. It's not a value that could've come from any and multiplied
RBGA value because the alpha, which doesn't change in conversion, would
multiply any RBG value and so set it to 0. The last RGBA looks like it might be
invalid to convert, since you would need to divide by 0 to convert from
premultiplied to unmultiplied form. However, this RGBA is entirely valid and is
the same as in premultiplied form. It represents an entirely transparent pixel.
If you started with an unmultiplied RGB of any value and an alpha of 0, the
premultiplied form would be the same. Note that the premultiplied form would
loose the RGB that the unmultiplied form had in this case.